[Music]
[Laughter]
wow
you don't see it a lot you don't see
good parenting anymore
amongst asians
well there's another if somebody beat up
an asian again yesterday it's all new
york what
it's only in new york come on man really
and let's and i don't know
let's just it's black guys hitting asian
women apparently somewhere in the
streets
and i hate to say that and i hate to
bring it up man and it just breaks my
heart it must be a big genre in porno
well you know what i would like to see
more ninja men come back
and start protecting their own yeah yeah
they know martial art oh dude yeah they
know marshall mathers all you need is a
japanese dude hyped up on some eminem
who's down to freaking kick some ass
japanese like uh what's the who's the
fireball kid
yeah he's older though man what if you
run into a guy like that
he's not out there the fireball kid
fireball kid good call man
pride last time saw cozy daddy huh a
koozie dog
oh dude i've been living in tennessee
rossi occupied all right
every meal i'm sorry i haven't gotten
out much
koozies are the things yeah i saw
someone put their baby in a koozie that
makes sense man
so yeah but no i love it i love it you
got that oh you got thick boy ones huh
brian johnson i just found it brian
johnson made these yeah
i made one for you too i think with the
coffee or the cup
he made the cozy that's that redneck
sweater
and i got you this too man stevie i know
oh [ __ ] i got i want you to be yeah i
got some [ __ ]
official merch i've had that for about a
year now
[ __ ] yeah that's that that's that hitter
baby
hell yeah you just it's a medium i don't
want you getting lost in there no no
that this is my thing yeah we don't want
any foul play with that black ass either
in that hoodie
that's not what it is you don't have to
bring that up again you don't have to
bring that up
i'm trying to help you i don't want
you're not helping me how are you
helping me i don't want your merch to
take a hit huh yeah how about black belt
because you know he's talked about on my
podcast yeah i did
he said it'd be a great nick i said how
about black belt
black belt well brendan likes to throw
people under the black box he said it'd
be a great date night
but and you said animal style in-n-out
burger oh sorry with that oh i saw that
movie by the way
which one the gin oh it's good right
it was just scary dude i know my movies
dog have you seen this [ __ ]
i don't watch a lot of movies that have
alcohol in the title
no it's d-j-i-n-n like a g-j-i-n-n it's
a little mix-created
yeah he's haunted yeah he gets haunted
he finds the satanic demonic
book in his closet 98 on rotten tomatoes
yeah dude
yeah but that's who's like what is it
well because he's deaf too right right
he's always deaf he's a no he's a mute
he's not deaf he can hear
he could hear he can't talk maybe nobody
taught him how to talk did they teach
him how to talk
do you know any of his backstage they
weren't doing the backstory that's what
i said
well that'll ruin the story if you tell
you spoiler do not tell me then yeah
and you watch cruella theo i watched i
didn't see cruella i'm
doing the build up i'm watching like the
original cartoon
looking through like some drawings and
stuff online and then i'm gonna get into
the um
actual thing the new deal yeah i don't
like to go straight it all the way there
you want some backstory what are you
doing you all right yeah yeah i'm just
i'm just prepping i'm prepping what's
going on here for what
who's that what's going on now hold on
didn't you go to a funeral
you look like you had a little too much
fun at a funeral i didn't like how you
were
on ig just blasting out there like it
was a reunion like a high school reunion
or some [ __ ] dog dude it was a kind of a
it was like a great school reunion yeah
i was at a funeral dude he passed away
this guy this kid i grew up and then
will the thrill myers
what happened overdosed he over too much
looking too much for a thrill it sounds
like
yeah a little too too much thrill one
day into little will one day
you know a little less thrilled my man
that was kind of heavy and also man if
you're gonna you know
and r.i.p man you know it was it was wow
was your close friend or you guys just
like drawing each other's backs in grade
school
he was a close friend man we were there
the first time somebody
ejaculated we ever saw some kid did it
in front of us were you checked off
he didn't some other kid did that should
probably be big thrill will
no we'll we here we were both there and
then the kid did it what grade were you
in
seventh grade ooh what a ballsy move
yeah yeah so you they invite you to the
funeral how does that work
out yeah they just they just invite i
mean you just you you know you hear
about it and then if you want to go you
can't
it's your hometown yeah god those are
sad they have food there
they had food after we got a food what
they have they had some chicken strips
they had um some of those sandwiches
like i don't want to call them death
sandwiches but like
those little sandwiches that they have
like at the um
the little uh triangles like that yeah
with them yeah
cheese at childhood cheese yeah sounds
like this funeral was on a budget
it was it was a divine little i don't
know how you decide food had a funeral
you know what i'm saying i'd probably do
whatever big will thrill wanted you know
you know what maybe you want some sloppy
joes my friend died i'm sorry
that they don't have the best menu there
yeah
dude come on you're the only one who
rolls in
to a and criticized yeah could have such
the food
man jeez dang they got the worst apps
here at grim reapers
like what is your problem man will
wouldn't appreciate this
oh yeah man no wonder will died he
probably wanted to get away from this
food brendan's gonna give her yelp
review on the [ __ ] funeral
yeah unbelievable man one star review on
this funeral man
that macaroni and cheese sucks
eulogy thumbs up
[Laughter]
dessert choices thumbs down
unbelievable r.i.p will man uh sorry you
know
it was just it was a lot i'm sorry your
friend passed away man funerals are the
worst
it was a lot and it was just a lot to
just i mean it was everything you know
it's just like when you get to those
moments and it's just like somebody's
climbing that stairway to heaven they're
out there
they just got there before us well wall
end up there they're ending up they're
going into that big black butt into the
future you know what i'm saying that
you're going to the dark it's easy to
sit here and practice but to really get
into the lord
really make the jokes yeah what drug was
it
you know i don't know and i don't want
to talk out of shop on him and i don't
think i am man i'll let you know
it's all respect yeah it's like
everybody struggles
man yeah and there i was right there
you're looking sharp man
thank you do you think yeah look at that
it's like a reboot for a bit back in the
80s
bad cop you know it looks like miami
vice rebel
right looks like you guys just got a
rehab
you both are celebrating it out of rehab
nice jacket man tango and bash jacket
man
looks like miami vices
and is that the uh grade school
uh ladies man scott sashfield that's a
great school ladies man this guy got all
the ladies dude when he
look at him i used to have to run uh
notes from him to like all the girls and
stuff
oh he's a real player huh and i had it
sometimes i would read them and pretend
they were from me and then run them too
now i have a pr
now i have a thing here sometimes i'm
gonna be honest i would check
no on them and run them back to the
girls yeah tight move
he's handsome dude yeah right move do it
don't leave me hanging like that and he
looks like ted cruz as well
looks like decker's now all the guys who
are ladies man in
high school look at that face it kind of
father time catches up with him
hold on bubba hey this isn't your dating
segment i know i know but
no he's got to give it up he's a
handsome man yeah look at him
but most of the guys that were really
ladies men crush in high school it
doesn't work out for them
later down life you know like that was
their good point that was their time to
crush
you think who was the who was the guy in
your in your grade that crushed
i forget his name but he was this new
kid he killed he don't forget his name
if you forget his name then you don't
know him he was crushing i remember he
had a
mitsubishi eclipse and every girl wanted
he had a mustache i was like god damn
daddy slow down
you got a full grown man mustache
or wife beer all the girls wanted
homecoming king and everything oh yeah
one at all
people used to come with this one fella
named bertrand was his name
and they call him bert and they call him
bert
and also he would get milk stuck in his
mustache nobody else could do it and
people would come from all over to see
it
a mustache in high school i mean you
might as well have a [ __ ] rolex
it's just uh ultimate power move dude
god damn god oh i got my black belt so
you tell that big [ __ ] gene over in
nashville i'm coming for a neck
huh you gotta tell that big [ __ ] what's
up now dude you gotta buy a black belt
you got a black belt dude but is it any
match for stevie's black
butt no belt no
belt versus butt and first of all you
beat these two dudes bro oh
congratulations
judgment but brandon you got a black
belt yeah oh good job i'm joking
congratulations bro yeah that's a big
deal dude yeah it's tough
yeah 14 years 14 years
why does it take so long it's not like
crying average is 10 years no karate can
get in a year those don't count yeah
congratulations man and who gave who who
uh i'm paul easton he's a henzo uh
gracie blackburn some brazilian guy
yeah it's a big deal when you get a
hanzo gracie black so do you have to
learn different submit like
american you have to know yeah they
rolled all the black belts for like an
hour
and then they just wasn't hard that was
hard no
were there some dudes you couldn't beat
i can carry my own i'm not gonna hate it
yeah they're monsters
they're good really yeah is it like
wrestling like jiu jitsu no you start
you start either on guard or in
somebody's garden oh okay i wish we
started from the feed yeah yeah
you don't get what's the one where you
get the little spo that little spoke
what do you mean now they took them when
you get your black belt they take and
they slap you with the black belt
well in the face it [ __ ] hurt and all
my sweaty back oh
god that's like that movie amistad yeah
that's why exactly what i thought i
didn't enjoy it
you got to be a big guy to do the jiu
jitsu though right no it's for small
guys actually
it's crazy so i could take a class you
could yeah hell yeah
it's made from other weight classes like
in wrestling like
a hundred pounds if you compete but i
don't think you're trying to win gold
here my man a panic
don't pressure him into it no he's the
one that wants to do it i'm trying to
tell you
okay brendan you know i went on uh
stevie's podcast he saw him
at his house oh yeah you saw where i
live and was his caretaker there what's
that guy's name norman no there's some
new girl there
what some new producer nice nice young
lady
new intern yeah nice young lady yeah
intern
yeah play smelt foreign yeah oh yeah
i lit palo santo uh sticks before he
came
you did oh yeah oh my god i was gonna
get cold and what's he from
who is that for you uh who's paulo santo
no palo santo is a type of it's like an
incense wood
you you light it up what was that what
that smelled i i
you did you like it it was cool oh i
thought you meant like i'm thinking of
gilbert burns
no no no he didn't he didn't burn
gilbert burns
no no it's a type of gilbert burns
holocaust
yeah i'm like it's like incense wood i'm
like holy stevie
it did smell like a portuguese in there
though i'll give you that only beautiful
stevie buys these ufc
men the ufc men scented candles only the
brazilian men's
what'd you think about my apartment man
it was cool man no be honest no i'd
break it down
no it's cozy yep it's like a senior care
center kind of meets
kind of like arts and crafts yeah it's
like a lot of anime on the wall
a lot of people uh like a couple
kitchenettes yes
i love that i was trying to it did give
off that black butt vibe like i could
smell the rubber in the room oh yeah
where the rubber meets the room that's
the title of this episode yep
that's it and look man i'm just glad
you're back man i'm glad to see you
healthy and doing well doing good
i'm doing good you know and bernie don't
try to get him involved in a bunch of
stuff
no i didn't he's the one i want to sign
up for dude you know bobby's gone for
six months
shooting a movie in hungary i'm not
surprised yeah see he's he was there i
look
900 pounds so that's cool you're a big
boy i know i don't realize i see myself
i just feel like i'm small and then i
see that and it ruins my day so that's
cool
brandon you're talking to a 9th degree
black butt over there all right
[Applause]
that might get written that
you know well that's why we brought you
on here we got we have some little
philly dubs through into that black butt
stuff
now it's legendary you should raffle it
you don't make cat's face
you sign it should i raffle it yeah it's
it's got wear and tear though you know
what i mean yeah but i think
does that raise the value though
yeah especially honestly and i'm not
gonna be be honest though oh i'll be
very i could take it okay go ahead
asian circles that raises the value
let's go to chin here
nah great before chin chimes in sure and
i know we want a real asian guy's
opinion here we do but you can't go to
china and buy used underwear in a ven
in a vending machine japan point that's
your point you can buy
pieces of chinese people on the [ __ ]
with a vpn
on the website what do you think ari
manas can get those for you easily dude
i just got a g
off that totally highly illegal oh you
make her grin on that but
really yeah a used butt like that
because we're like i'm gonna rub it up
let's go to the captain himself dude
chin how should he uh market this black
butt channel how do you sell him that uh
yeah to the asian market or what he the
the asian ebay the libre the leader
after learning about all this only fan
stuff you can actually probably sell it
for a good amount of money
and you're out of your own person this
is my selling point because i've only
used the vagina part
the butthole has not been touched right
hey nobody's no nobody's believing that
you can say
about it okay sorry i feel like we've
kind of discussed it enough are you
hungry bro
i'm hungry dog but i'm sick of going to
the grocery store man
are you hungry i'm hungry and that's why
i use hello fresh because i don't even
mess with the grocery store anymore
dog we haven't forget about it i count
on hellofresh to make home
cooking easy we hungry we are affordable
man
i want civilians i got you doggy it's
why it's america's number one meal kit
all right we got you covered man
try hello fresh quick and easy meals 15
15-20 minutes you got 20 minutes
dinner breakfast on the go all right
tons of options for you
enjoy a wide variety it's easy delicious
options for all three meals a day plus
every snack and special street in
between
with hello friends takis takis go to
hellofresh.com
12 king and use the code 12 king for 12
free meals free meals including free
shipping
again that's hellofresh.com that was our
dad's name richie
use the code 12 king and you get 12 free
meals
hellofresh america's number one meal kit
i met a girl and donna
was her name man my hair
it's looking nice daddy what you using
dog
what are you doing to keep it i'm
keeping
it with keeps dude two out of three
men will experience hair loss by 35 oh
it's sad you can almost go touch a man
and that that man is having hair loss
problems not good man keeps offering a
simple stress free way to keep your
freaking hair
low-cost treatment start just ten
dollars per month keeps offers generic
versions all right
discreet little package shows up at your
door discrete that's the thing about my
results
you order it it's almost like getting
that playboy that penthouse or that
hustler mag
nobody needs to know man prevention is
key treatments can take four to six
months
so act fast if you're ready to look like
theovon with them long locks out the
back go to k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash cats to receive your first
month's free
treatment that's k-e-e-p-s dot
cats to get your first month free
keeps.com
cats brandon your showtime brother
jake paul sent in a message for us
gearing up for his big fight
oh geez that is that's this fight this
weekend man i gotta go down there on
thursday you're going home
who's you're fighting jake um jake
paul's fighting woodley that's in august
but uh
logan paul floyd mayweather this weekend
do you think that's a real fight
which one the floyd versus logan
yes yes yeah it's real it's not for
no entertainment that one time uh floyd
fought tension or whatever in japan
kickboxer
and he knocked out the [ __ ] kind of
yeah it seemed like a chain called
[ __ ] yeah
but it's like people think the ben
asking jake paul fight was fixed and
that's insane no you ever been
hit with a [ __ ] block but it was
technically fixed in the sense that ben
askren had no intention of trying to win
i feel like
he still got knocked out for reals
though it's not arrested
yeah he needs to strike he just got
knocked out but if you have no plan to
not get knocked out you'll probably get
knocked out is that probably true
against somebody that's fighting he was
just looking for payday
and jake was not jake was there to fight
yeah but you know for a takedown right
he's looking to wrestle right yeah but
it's a boxing match yeah
he knew it in advance you couldn't let's
stick to black butts so anyways
jake versus woodley's uh that to me
that's a little just talk to him like
that i don't want to apologize i want to
apologize
i'm sorry
[Music]
no i know your family history i want to
apologize no no no no no no no no you
guys have been through a lot of [ __ ]
dead i didn't know it's a boxing match
sorry yes boxing oh yeah
but now if it was mma yeah jake would
get tooled
you'd get taken down yeah still don't
even let's see what jake has to say
about all right sorry
yeah i'm sorry what's up brennan what's
up theo it's your boy jake
i told you i wasn't playing around baby
signed a show time
first up t woods gonna give him that
aspirin treatment
that face down ass up same [ __ ]
different day
predicting third round knockout he ain't
quick enough and big enough to take
these hands
i might have to he comes out of my head
throw him in that hard scarf [ __ ] who
knows
but uh out here getting some of that
cross training sweat my ass off
wow what was that floyd yeah
yeah no no no problem sir we gotta get
that ground
this guy's young there man anytime you
seen above ground pool they used to have
a lot of men in our area would meet up
they had an abandoned above-ground pool
and people said it was haunted
yo yeah and a lot of men would meet up
in there and put chairs like uh
he's in a motor home park too as well
would put
um what do those chairs do that like the
launchers yes lawn chairs in there and
they'd sit there and smoke dope
what a good time get wild i'd do that
right it was like a nightclub kind of
butt in
like in your yard huh oh yeah yeah a lot
of dark [ __ ] goes down there dog
i would do that right now with everybody
in here we should get a
above ground pool with lawn chips i
would we can't why don't we have
any room in here we just put this thing
in here on the other what we got in the
maybe the other room yeah
i'm impressed by him he's confident he's
confident but he
man look i'm going to say this woodley
goes with those
big strike hands i don't i think he can
see that kind of stuff coming that's
what i just think man
really beats him you know woodley's no i
don't think so woodley's a slight
underdog i don't think
he's got more experience than this guy
right as of ufc
fighter woodley hasn't won a round in 20
rounds
he's also mainly a wrestler too though
but uh we're looking strike
wild card boxing train like willie's the
real deal it's a good fight
that's a good fight can he box or does
he just have those
freaking ball balls in the box yeah and
i
mean the guy obviously will beat all of
us he would probably have you for lunch
hey i'm not disputing that look and i
think it'd be he's a big boy though he
looked
like your size uh jake no he's not
myself okay
yeah that was actually how uh jake uh
finished his video he said debate club
me or t
wood we had fake paul calling our buddy
no bulldog i'm saying uh we got
i'm gonna say uh jake stevie i don't
know i don't see i don't know
much about that guy uh nick who you got
you're you're educated
i think i'm on jake paul now like
woody's only sucks dude but i think
mentally woodley's just not there
anymore so yeah
and i think it's jake paul by decision
though that's what i think how many
rounds does it go how many rounds do
they allow
it'll be eight rounds i don't know if
lily's gonna go e-ball
i'm going woodley all the way oh wow
yeah i i'm
when i first found out about the fights
i just went down the rabbit hole and
started watching like all of his
striking
but you watched the old woodley clips
when he fought you know some of those
older dudes and he has leg kicks than
the threat of a takedown and all the
clips you watched yeah no there was no
leg kicks in them oh they were all just
mainly boxing yeah he has that overhead
left
south paw yeah but that's also an older
wood that's the old videos you're
watching
you know it's tough to just know what
his what what makes him have a lot of
desire
a nice guy awesome doesn't look like he
wants to be in there anymore
well i find this fascinating because
it's a it's who knows what's gonna
happen
yeah but remember we got that we got on
the same train with the other one when
the man was saying
yeah i didn't think i was gonna go down
like that i think that woodley like you
know where the beef that woodley had
with
uh jake paul's uh jake paul's friend
corner man yeah corner man he's a legit
boxer
i think it's gonna be you know how floyd
and logan are like
everyone thinks that floyd's gonna go
after logan harder about the whole
gotcha half yeah
i think the same mentality is running
through woodley's head like because
he was disrespected by his cornerman
yeah that's fair
well so a couple weeks ago we uh
last time stevie was in here we just
started talking about his dating life
and that
we think he's we think he needs to put
himself out there more and some
people just picked up the whisper and
they started setting themselves up and
smelled my breath
man well stevie that's there's a lot of
things going on with me you've seen
where i live
there's a lot of things there's poo
going on right here yeah we gotta fix
that
you can easily take some ginger pills
now if it's halitos yeah
but hey i'll go along with it i'll just
go along with you dude and also you
don't
don't don't [ __ ] on the apartment man
the apartment's a nice time thank you
very much
yeah but i don't have a card dude you
have a hair taker there's uber
take her to in-n-out burger oh yeah now
we're talking daddy
you can't be ashamed of what's going on
in your life man if you love in and out
that's
going along with it so what's going on
here
what's going on now we i think we
discussed you're actively interested in
finding someone right
um not really but i'm just going along
with it let's see if that because
it's it's entertaining right i mean i
mean but these are yeah but what
happened look at this little dime piece
man you want to have her over the
apartment look at anime he doesn't know
what's going on right here
there's things going on down here too oh
yeah yeah erectile dysfunction no
just you know it gets dry you know the
nuts get dry
i don't know what that means
everyone's just pop what does that mean
even the people in there
whose must get dry how old are you
dry nuts babies hold up dry
dry nuts baby what's that mean you don't
want it do you want me to show you after
we'll go in the bathroom yeah i'll put
my lines down yeah i'll look the other
way
you got dandruff right here why don't we
show them what's going on down here and
i guarantee you
no submissions let's not let it out you
actually
i don't want to see wiener so you have
to face that way
that camera style yeah
i'm with theo though i don't see trunk
either you got a bulldog your nuts out
the back
no it's okay we'll do it afterwards all
right we'll take it we'll do it
afterwards we won't do it afterwards
that's weird when the cameras are off
but you agreed with him at first
i'll just bring we'll just go into the
bathroom come on it's a bro thing
huh it's a proper thing we're all pros
here man
well let me have a say and i don't want
to
we'll all go in there and then we'll go
into a stall and i'll go see guys are
they like flaky
it gets dry it gets dry it's so strange
it's really easy for you to just turn
around and show them a little bit now
i don't want it because i know the
editorial i just don't want to show them
what
won't you trust timmy's freaking chin
he's not going to let you down this big
nut sack okay hold up let's
let's take a look inside okay you know
what
tell me what that is it's like dried
squid
it's like squid turkey squid jerky yeah
it's delicious
it's delicious and that's awesome but it
looks really ashy it's
super dry and ashy yeah that's awesome
yeah
it's dry it's dry yeah so go let's do
the let's see
guys what's up man he's not i just i
just prepped myself for it let's go
no it sounds like he's you're really
gonna meet a great yeah ladies let's
tell them about that after
yeah okay well thank you some people
will put up with their niche
it's actually ashy there's like ash on
there
see see what i'm talking about reminds
me of that on a date they'll get it
okay they'll get that it reminds me this
fella new name boo boo tyson growing up
what happened to him dry nuts his leg
got burnt up in a
garage fire you look like freddy krueger
huh you look great
now we managed it well it was real it
was all merged together bone muscle
now you're looking at me a little
differently there's something going on
right now i'm worried about your nut
section yeah because
i'm not worried about any of that man i
just want you to find love man i want
you to find a future
that you can enjoy let's see if we can
find anything look man a lot of times
something will come back and get you and
that's karma it is karma yeah
we had a girl at our school named karma
wilson ooh damn
[Music]
struggle city that's funny i think she
was a healthy nickel man when i met her
we were children also so i mean i only
knew when she was 11.
karma will get you man thank god for
credit karma has always been there to
help you make better financial decisions
and now they want to help you
even more yup credit is tough man if you
got credit no credit discredit that
credit
credit karma money is brand new checking
account where you can win
cash reimbursements for making purchase
you buy stuff
why not get reimbursed dude just pay
with your debit card and if you win
you'll be notified on the spot
instant karma cash right to your
freaking bank account
all right there's no minimum balance
requirements no overdraft fees no
free and free withdrawals from a network
of over 50
000 atms i mean you could be under water
and they probably have atm under there
credit karma money progress starts here
right now visit creditkarma.com
win money purchase open your free
account and start winning instant
comma go to creditkarma.com
win money to sign up for free and start
winning instant karma's
that's creditkarma.com win money instant
karma is sponsored by credit karma
no purchase necessary exclusions and
terms apply see rules
bank and service provided by mvb bank
incorporation
member fdic maximum balance and transfer
limits apply credit karma.com
look daddy you know what i'm saying is
uh a lot of times you see a swan you see
a duck
and you say damn where am i
and i say all birds matter man oh birds
matter baby
warmer weather is here and people are
starting to feel more hopeful
about the rest of the year and the rest
of their lives get out and walk a little
bit
man yup try all birds tree runners
discover your perfect
pair at allbirds.com they're made from
sustainable
natural material that feel light on your
feet and are better for the planet
do you like the planet i love it man the
simple it's versatile design makes the
tree runner a perfect gift
or just wear it for yourself man rock
the kicks you know i love my kids
that's allbirds.com this dude is birded
up man what's that on your feet a duck a
swan that's all birds baby
birds up ducks down yeah packaging made
from 90
recycled cardboard uh shopping bags
everything you look dope man go to
allbirds.com a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s
dot com if you don't spell all birds
probably shouldn't be wearing shoes
allbirds.com okay what do you got here
what do you got look at the little girl
brendan nick chappelle cat chin all of
you in the studio
there's so many that's enough um
i am submitting for a date with stevie
wiebe my name is mandy i'm 29 and i live
in california
i'm still a few hours away from you guys
so i'm sorry you still have to pay for a
flight
but i do have a few reasons why i think
i would be a good fit i also got out of
a relationship
not too long ago probably within the
same time frame as you stevie so
you know we could talk about our
feelings have a good you know cry about
it like japanese women
um the second reason why is i don't have
a relationship with my dad
so he can't break us up also i am not
asian as far as i know but my mom looks
very filipina so
you know i might have a little bit of
asian to me somewhere and i could
probably get some more asian in me as
well
that's it guys gang gang buzz buzz
beautiful nice what'd you say but she
don't
did you guys submit that to her we got
to hear this last year
would she end with you know i might have
a little bit of asian to me somewhere
and i could probably get some more asian
in me as well
she seems fun for sure i don't know if
this is like the wife material really
she wants some of that squid jerky daddy
you think so
yeah she wants some of that you want
some of that eel sauce
papa you think so she wants some of that
skin graft urchin dog
yeah dog your suitor dumper two this is
an older cat
and this is michael jackson's son
easy there let's get give everyone a
chance
don't do no michael jackson hold on hold
on give everyone a chance
you already said nobody has a chance
after we spent years
shut it down a great deal come on give
her a chance just give everyone a chance
okay it'll be hard
you just expect the same out of you you
know
uh this is amanda rose i'm in montana hi
stevie weeby this video is
mainly for you um so a little bit about
me
i'm in montana i'm half south korean
and scottish check um i'm a very total
uh scott korean um
like six one um i just think you're
super cute stevie and um
i watch your guys show all the time and
i want to let you know i'm single
and i want to do you so wow
wait a minute what is she doing and
she's bodied up what did she say at the
end man she said she wants to date you
what did she say so she wants you put
you in her pocket and feel your
ashy easy there
easy so yeah
she's cute man dude how tall is she
6'1 i'm 5'4 yeah bro does that mean
you know what that means you do the math
there she's gonna hit four she's gonna
hit you
do you know how tall much taller that is
you're six two six four
okay you're six four yeah she's six one
you look like a boss dude you look like
a badass
yes now chen can you help out yeah you
look like a boss i just don't understand
why there's so much like
people aren't like you know i don't like
your attitude stevie
because because look at her she's
gorgeous dog
look at that we're showing you dying
dude i'm 5'4 oh darling
what are we doing david i'm saying do
you guys have a lot of nuts out
you have to climb up a ladder you know
what i mean then ladder up you weaker
bastard
koala club yeah you could be her little
koala do that koala
and she's bodied up dog bro look at that
look at them
cheeks dad she's got ink too huh yeah
mommy
oh jesus that yellow stone mama i don't
know why
she has a freaking mayflower on her arm
can we zoom in on that oh
lord bro that means you're shiffy doug
your ship has come in
daddy do you think so is that the
mothership is that the mother ship yeah
your jacket
dude oh dude it's just
a match
and he looks dry it's perfect perfect
stevie that's a perfect is that a sign
dude that has to be a sign hey
take care drink nuts dry nuts squid dry
squid also
brendon no no look at that stay with me
here i'm waiting i just said
i didn't see this i said my nuts are
like dry squid
and she's got squid on her arm is that a
sign or what near her elbow too where
it's usually ashy
but montana what am i gonna do what are
you you're gonna get married
are you i don't even know where montana
is what it maybe next week we set up a
zoom call with her and have a meet
yeah that's exactly it i want to know
this also so excited
that's your problem man monta look at
that ass
i know but where is montana man you know
it's about a two-hour flight from that's
not two hours
isn't that in the midwest no i've been
oh my goodness straight shut up oh it's
up north it's like it's
beautiful it's my favorite one of my
favorite places yeah look at that [ __ ]
the nina the penta and the santo paolo
dog you've got
this can you zoom in on the bathing suit
um you mean that ass daddy that korean
ass hold up let me just take
you you don't see a lot of koreans with
an ass like that either that now she has
a bruise and that's whatever that's cool
that she has nice skin man
yeah and she's got korean but that's
joking
hmm what do you think brandon i mean
home run i would listen
we can't do much better than this but
that's i like that gold chair
and sell that this guy's introducing his
sister well hold on just a second wait
wait is this
i don't think is this appropriate i mean
this is let's sister
okay let's give it a chance these days
people are doing whatever they can yeah
so also this lady can we zoom back up to
a decent part of the woman so i can
i mean that's jesus christ what kind of
place are we running here
look stevie that's some nice skin i have
to admit she's got nice skin
now you said how can we even get to
where she lives in montana
or have you ever heard of a man called
fdr can you bring up a picture of this
man yeah
and what he did for the interstate
highway system
trains national parks this guy's looking
at me so concerned
brendan i'm not concerned this is a home
run i'd theo did all he could here
i know you guys roosevelt effort guys
let me tell you what this guy did all
right tell him i know you guys probably
don't believe him or whatever because
he's white
but this guy put in all the interstates
all the train tracks this guy did yeah
easily
making a way for you to get to someone
you want to love today
that's a ford fiesta away isn't it yeah
that's a short
plane ride or a long drive yeah when
you're like how can we get there like
it's lewis and clark times or something
like there's
malaria she lives in korea dude montana
that's an easy straight shot
real poo breath dry nut brush your teeth
and take a shower
let's flee dip him i i think he has i
think he has happened
i think he has halitosis no you don't
tar somebody you can't tire a human
you can flee dip though can you flee dip
human can you look that next
little honey bath maybe yeah i mean six
too man i don't think i've ever gotten
a woman six one i mean i have never
gotten with the woman over
please flea dip human can you put that
can you flee that human
oh yeah there you go it's flea powder's
safe for humans there we go there we go
but i don't have fleas on me
according to you you really are
struggling bro well i would say you're
you're ashy nuts have something going on
that we need to figure out
yep and larva by drying them out so it
could help you it's toxic you guys want
to see it you want to go to the bathroom
and check it out i would like to see it
here so i don't have to go into a secret
location where you see your nuts
okay maybe maybe some head and shoulders
on your neck you know what or maybe
a carmex that worked too um
vaseline vaseline is great okay just oil
them up dog yeah
that's an easy dude i appreciate the
effort you guys this is
this is really interesting that's a home
run
seriously yeah the sixth one girl and
she's part korean
and she's a chin i don't like what
you're doing right now because you're
playing devil's advocate it's
i know what you're doing she has a cute
smile oh nice skin
devil's advocate with brad pitt is that
with brad pitt oh no but it's just the
same tiana reeves yeah
and and she was like the first
submission
even before we put it on social media
she sent in a submission that she wanted
to date you she's a look and she's alive
she heard about
the breast stuff already you've talked
about it many times yeah nuts and your
[ __ ] breath don't scare me
uh you can't hear the beginning of it
but uh he's got a great video so
he just introduces himself and says he's
talking about a sister okay gotcha
my sister who is a 27 year old
well no i think he's 28 now but she has
recently split up
dating a douchebag she's a
i don't know she's pretty cool she
smokes weeds you'll fist fight and
we we're we got um some korean innocent
that matters porter crane i know you
can't tell by me but cucos i'll send
some pictures in with her i'm telling
right now we could
this could work moose and stevie
gang gang buzz buzz color moose you
could wrestle those little conor
mcgregors right there yeah
uh is those her kids maybe it could be
her ex-husband no stevie
do you like uh bigger women uh
i've been with the yeah i've i've had my
fair share uh-huh
well it's an 80-pound test on that black
bottoms like an 80-pound test and how
much does everything weigh uh
it's pretty heavy it's pretty heavy yeah
a couple pounds if you have to have
one a person help you lift whatever
thing you're like whatever sex object
you're
handling or something then you you'll be
fine with a real woman yeah
and they could start like a tandem
podcast stevie and moose
the moose no the moose and stevie the
moose and steve the great white
north you could talk about her butt yeah
yes although did he say what state he's
in
he didn't he did it she seems real nice
stevie these are three
very pretty the first one good variety
pack yeah good variety
oh check out the forehead on this one
looks like mega mine oh man
and just like that you know what like
this is what's wrong with this show wait
what's wrong let me tell you give it a
[ __ ] tell them
i'm going to tell you what's wrong
here's the problem [ __ ] tell her
yeah go ahead that was too much but be
honest about it
be honest this is what's wrong with this
show tell him yeah just be honest she
got
[ __ ] hulk tending in the back [ __ ]
45 minutes of experience okay just
rattling off ideas
all right you got nick who is under so
much influence of thc
who can barely keep his eyes open today
he wore a bright orange sweatshirt
just so he'd know he's here right you
got
chin there's nothing who i don't even
think knows that he's here
seven words
[ __ ] each week reasonably offer
nothing for the program okay yeah stevie
who is coming here
begging looking for love looking for
love we brought it
and we brought it and we brought you
i'm sorry meatball can we give it a
chance you're standing we got spam
tonsil in the back right here
let's give everyone a chance man this
[ __ ] pig appendix
is sitting in the back over here just
judging all these women
[ __ ] skunk gonad over here in the
distance
i'm a [ __ ] i'm gonna sick moose on
you how about that meatball
nick is just already remember i was in
the studio i was wearing orange
she's got orange hair okay let's give
margaret a chance
give her a shot look give her something
dude well i know
that's why i'm fixated on the videos
guys you know
oh my god yeah crazy
have i been eating crazy crunch it's not
crazy
this is reality baby look hi
we're greetings i am 27 i'm from san
antonio texas
i'm a web designer i like to cook
i like to bake i like to do outdoorsy
things
um i love animals um
i think stevie should pick me to go on
his date
because i don't really know how many
um options are gonna be out there and
bro she wants some of that grimace dog
you feel me that little purple muppet
it seemed like it was like a save a wish
foundation i don't know
it's making wishes i don't know
kind of caught me no hold up you're on a
fifth string podcast
he's like an alien i don't know how many
people will be you know
open-minded for you know this kind of
yeah we're doing our best thing
i know i know but you know she made it
seem it was kind of
there's a backhand but it could be a lot
she might be i mean a lot
okay she's not excuse me going through a
meditational thing right now
i think he's a dream of crazy christmas
but am i wrong brendan like the way she
made it
the pitch oh mama look at this hold up
man we need to be back baby
crazy crunch mom aren't gonna work out
look at this baby
we're doing this maybe single yourself
so i feel like you could get some of the
leftovers the fun thing
they're all like tatted too huh come on
man give her a shot look at that hair
man
i see me this is castro
called him guess give her a shot dude
seriously
what do you know how many hours she put
getting that hair color what are you
talking about
i'm just over here yes i'm being mindful
is what it's
it's that's what it's called i'm being
mindful let's go let's go
stevie's got a great point theo's single
too keep your eye out
that montana mama don't work out for him
hey
i'm being mindful my head's been in the
game i'm in the game too brother look
i'm fixated on her i'm listening to
everything
they're saying right shame okay somehow
i'm the bad guy
okay that's fine um i heard you her
name's natalie and she's single and
ready to mingle so i thought i would
tell you a little bit about myself
i am brown hair blue eyes
six feet tall my hobbies
include going hiking being outdoors
i love the beach i just got back um
i love muay thai i love weightlifting um
just staying physically fit is a passion
of mine
um love to laugh so if you ever wanted
to get together and go on a date
sometime
you know who to call girl next door hit
me up you're not the girl next door
but the thing is again this would be fun
i like her energy
right her energy is really positive she
she would be the funniest thing
she'd be the funnest date if you're next
door to burning man yeah
look first of all i want to win that
natty dude natty looks nice i'll say
that
yeah positive attitude i guess i'm
positive right now look i'm mindful
he's coming around yeah he's coming
around but again
i'm five four she would she say six foot
six foot flat we should get c beyond
short king's
i've never heard such a diff you're just
stevie i want to get you out of this
defeatist
attitude man you're [ __ ] on yourself
that beat up somebody that was big
i'm a realist sure
he's fighting other small guys but yeah
when he first started he won
the short guys were getting it done ufc
one dude
do you have seat one median short guys
can get it done
it's historic now here's the thing
you're five four it's me tough to get a
lot of submissions under five
it is yeah yeah why would you say that
because big queens like it
big queens want you dude yeah they want
that baby they want that front side
piggy back
you know they want to put you on their
backs she seems great she would be the
funnest data she seems like a nice
person
yeah you guys could do all these like
role birthing role plays you could do it
all
but she does seem i don't want to um
generalize she does seem like
uh you know like the not the burning man
thing but a free spirit but yeah cause
i'm i'm so
you know what i mean yeah so you're a
little more reserved she at least
looks like i don't know if i'm
generalizing again no go ahead but maybe
she at least smokes
pot 100 yeah maybe a little acid on the
side
yes and that's fine yeah that's that's
good to be that experimental
person and you get to be the safeguard
you get to be the where the pants and
the relationships right right
did she say where she's located as well
[Music]
seattle oregon can the producers help
with that where she located guys
uh she didn't include it but uh we we
told the people from the beach
we told the people if stevie agreed we'd
we'd fly her out okay
okay hopefully she's not in australia
because that's not how i'm not trying to
be routine man i just want you to find
you know like
i i guess i felt at some point that you
weren't
looking to have somebody you know and
then when you start going to brendon for
suggestions i'm not saying that's a bad
idea but
it's probably not one of the top 10
ideas you could have now there's that
but there's also a guy here who's
been in successful relationships and if
you're going to take advice from
this one that's a good point but he has
experience he has life experience
it's never worked out it's ended up yeah
but he's had moments
right that's a moment dude i've had
definitely kind of like i'm sort of like
the jason williams of sex
yeah yeah how do you meet you you got a
knee injury
how do you meet your gals i meet them
through
probably dms or in person in person kind
of these days more a little bit
but but i'm not on the apps you know
uh and then also my biggest problem is
i'm just not ready to i've just
i get too many hang ups about commitment
yeah i hear you and i think you have
some of those hang ups
oh yeah yeah i mean you can't even
commit obviously to having
and i'm not judging but you can't even
commit to having fresh breath on a date
and that's not a big thing i don't think
unless and y'all's culture is that a big
thing in y'all's culture it is a big
thing
what no well then we don't go to the
dentist that's that's the problem the
lee brother
bob too bob doesn't go i don't go bob
has [ __ ] breath too bob had a tooth
taken out through his butt once yeah
that's so wrong but we just let it fall
out we have three let's go around the
room and discuss kind of where we feel
like we're at those areas
that's it that's all we have that's
right great choices and thank you to
everybody that sent in somebody i mean
people sending people literally
thoughtful i mean here's
really thoughtful you got to think that
a woman or a man out there who have a
sister
made a video and said hey i'm willing to
put myself out there
to you goons we are and they know we're
gonna roast absolutely
and they know we're going to roast them
yeah yeah we are seven and if you look
around this room i see some of the
saddest men that i've ever seen
i agree it looks like that funeral you
went to it does
so you see there's a couple prospects
you're saying right i think montana is
number one
i think the moose would be a good time
and i think homegirl that was just on
who looks like part of the manson family
would be one hell of a date
and that this is all we got that's all
we got
those are pretty good those are pretty
[ __ ] good better than none right it's
like incredible
none right there was more right it was
just these are the top three
yeah yeah these are the good ones let's
go around the room and say uh
i think you guys are just saying that
just despair 100
i'd rather know the truth and i could
live with it
but just tell me were those the only no
i could live with it
bro it's five more than you had i know
i'm that's not my point you're dating
one another
am i being picky
yeah i got a little bit of oral the
other night in my own town behind a nail
salon
and that's oh and i'll be honest but at
least i went out there and gave it a
shot and i had
the girl maybe buy her an alternator too
the girl may pay for a new alternator
for her car yeah
at least you could do it but that's the
times we're in man you got to at least
at least i
got out you put yourself out thank you
yeah i'm proud of you thank you and
beautiful cool cool blow job behind the
nail salon dude you're doing it
cool gal man you know saturday fast
montana's great the girl from burning
man seems fun
big moose seems a good time we have
she's got some kids though huh
are those her kids she did have a couple
kids i think he'd be a good dad stevie
you're very kind soul
i mean i could hardly take care of
myself that's a lot you've seen where i
i don't whoa yeah
this is renee from ogden utah
i wanted to send my submission
for stevie weeby she's at theo to go
on a date he said all three of us um a
couple of things i like to do
is hula hoop be outside
he has an erection you know just joking
around being with short asian dudes
um i'm a waitress part
i also do adapted pe part-time which is
pe with special needs kids
oh yeah um
so she's up for it i'd be down to come
to l.a to go on a date with you stevie
and mama is i don't like what you're
doing over because every girl you're
like doing a whole bulls
like a bullseye thing brendan i'm gonna
keep talking to him
now what are you saying what are you
saying here stevie you're looking you're
liking
i mean she's she's attractive woman yeah
i can't i can't lie to you i can't lie
to you stevie they've all been
attractive women yeah they're all
attractive some more than cute yeah
yeah all of them you toss closer than
montana too this is more your style
can i tell you something uh a pro yeah
let's hear some respect because she's
wearing a print because i like
skateboarding and she has a
skateboarding um
primitive so you know that's that's cool
she's into like
you know it's like someone wearing like
a mma brand you like
yeah it would turn you off okay or yeah
or somebody wearing like a um ged
sweater sweater
exactly what do you all think
she's definitely the prettiest out of
the bunch that's not true i mean she's
beautiful girl
really i think they're all i think
honest out there i think all these are
homeless
is that utah though what's utah that's
like a mormon
that's that's an hour and a half flight
my man it's close isn't it
and she said she she likes to do mma
with
you know people with autism or whatever
you could you could easily
hold up are you saying you're saying i'm
autistic dude
dude what do you say you saying i am are
you saying he's on this side
like what are you saying i am special
needs
but are you saying everybody in this
room is look at where we are i know but
are you saying i
am dude we're on a podcast based upon a
rat and a bee
okay in a basement good boy freaking
in scenic we're on the spectrum here
this is the bottom of the mirror
you guys are doing well i've seen your
views who we are over
yeah you guys got good views on youtube
you guys are doing great
you know what also has good views on
youtube that video of trucks that are
too tall to go under those bridges
that is 70 million views yeah you guys
are doing
great and some of the videos and there
were repeats they just snuck them in
again to keep
an angle yeah this is fun dude dude i
think we found love you guys got some
more
yeah this is fun look i think we have
some good options chen what do you see
here
two more two more this is two more turn
out of the bunch so far who would you
pick yeah let's go ahead and see here
i think we have the same top two i think
we have the same top two montana and
utah
am i right you know god damn
he like you know you know what's weird
though i don't know how tall that the
last girl is because she
could be she could be short or she could
be tall she's short okay
she's short so then you know i'm leaning
towards she's tall she'll tell you
leaning towards you just fit too yeah
you think so it's cute
slender like like a swimmer's body works
out
yeah yep it's like a good thick i think
yeah she looks like
what about the uh
tick tock that we put up with stevie
let's see that
and we sent this also to a lot of the
women is to let them know
the type of man you get to have with
stevie okay there you go you're attached
i didn't know you had this footage i
don't know
you have to start acting like you're a
catch dude yeah you're selling yourself
short do you think so
i really yeah i'm just being honest with
it though you know this is
almost too much you think so brendan
don't tell him that
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that was edited together schizophrenic
alien that didn't
happen in real time really that didn't
happen to really kill myself
no please don't no no no no no no you
can't yeah please don't do it
no no no yeah i know this is and we
gotta pay that party hold up hold up
brandon brennan i really really
appreciate what you guys have done
i'm i'm dying today no you're not i just
realized
epiphany i saw the reality of me
that theme music didn't help that the
music did not
that was put together by i'm not sure
someone who could work with us uh but i
think look man i think that captures
some of your essence though and that you
are that x-file
i think you're a cat schizophrenic i
think you're a catch and
you gotta start walking a little more
there is no posture
i think you're a cat stevie we need to
people love this whole episode
um and i would like to be in the editing
room and
we'll just we'll just cut everything out
we'll keep the the beginning was good
about the boxing talk
i like that yeah just keep that we'll
just make it a 10-minute episode
where do you stand looking for love what
do you think here nick and look see and
then
go on nick i'm sorry i just i just truly
believe that we found it in that second
submission from montana yeah uh
she usually she's the most eager uh
i i really think she is looking for love
the other one seemed like
they were cats fans wanted to send a
nice video a little bit to me
oh you know she was more real about it i
in my in my
humble opinion i would i would love to
have you two talk
she did seem sweet i liked the first i
liked the first girl that sent in
she seemed sweet she seemed very sweet
she seemed possibly latina and i think
you need
latino women are very loved latinas who
doesn't love them
okay yeah but they're very organized
they will [ __ ] you up
they will [ __ ] your friends up your car
on fire yeah they will set your
coache they fuego you know what i'm
saying brother [ __ ] are for real dawg
tell me about it you know what i'm
saying so yeah there you go real talk
huh
real talk yeah and so i think you need
i'm just trying to think what you really
could use
man because at a certain point i just
don't want you to end up lonely like me
like nick like chin nick has someone but
still is lonely
we're still alive like brendan but
brendan has a whole family
or like that kid other than that you're
the only one that's actually with a
woman
yeah doing it i have a girlfriend we're
all single
right i mean not bad it's not so bad
right chin's married
are you married no i'm not married being
single is not so bad it's not good
though at your guys age
it was fun being i actually love being
single and nick what do these people
need to know about dating an asian
person that you can tell us because i
knew your girlfriend is uh korean
uh it's really nice because if their
family comes over they stay for like 15
minutes tops
it's very like they don't want to bother
you yeah you eat they
they leave don't overstep their
boundaries he's pretty sick um
i don't i don't know if all korean dads
cut or asian dads cut hair but my
girlfriend's dad whose vietnamese dad
cuts my hair
okay so you got a barber out of it save
money
got a barber yeah you saved money you
have a caretaker that had you know
you don't say it like get you have to
get what you what god has given you bro
i know but okay let's play gem two we
have the date
i i meet her at mcdonald's uh we get
a big mac happy meal no and then
she smells my poo breath okay it was
nice to meet you no
no we're gonna get somebody to brush
your teeth whatever that's how it's not
gonna go that way we're gonna fix your
breath
we're gonna oil up them nuts and we're
going to send you on a real date create
a barbecue
little [ __ ] hospice we'll get you
into hospice care for a week
they do what do they do hospice they
take care of you yep brush your teeth
brush your butt
that's a nursing home isn't it yeah but
it's in your house they come to you
so i have a nurse come over and clean my
nuts and somebody
you're not doing it you're a good point
good point
we're trying to god man this is like
you're working with me yeah now here's
another submission that came in
this is just a nice guy it's this guy's
birthday today he doesn't even have a
segment he's just
a nice message he's a nice guy watch
stevie choose him hey brandon help you
um my name is pranjal pathak and i'm
from india
i just want to let you know that you
guys are [ __ ] amazing and
we love your dark humor over here you
guys have no idea that you are paper
thin clothes to boom in india
and today is my birthday please do wish
me
my birthday and peace i love you thank
you so much
panzo bhatta rock baby what's up baby
what a nice guy
gang gang bro dude what a nice guy happy
birthday yeah god bless you
set a hair on him too great shirt right
here
and look i've been in india man i love
you guys over there dude i saw a monkey
you guys got fans in india that says a
lot
i saw a monkey with a wrist watch on
there wow probably stole it
yeah yeah and look let me tell you he
was punching his fist like this
he's like i'm not joking that's india
dude
and that is india india is no joke dude
i don't have your head on a swivel
you ever driven down an interstate i saw
people sleeping on the interstate on the
side
you've been there huh yeah you know what
they call the poor people in india
the untouchables yep they think they did
something bad in previous life and
that's why they're poor like kevin
costner it doesn't make sense
yeah it doesn't make great sense so yeah
i appreciate it so
that's really fun man real i want to
thank nick thank you
thank you nick thank you guys we
appreciate it that was really a lot
yeah we appreciate it yeah man i know
you guys had to look deep
no man christian thank you so much and
what do you think can we set you up with
one of these gals well let's talk about
it let's go to the bathroom and uh
let's go back and see his nuts see how
bad it is
let's go take a trip real quick i'll
talk about that
i will walk that path for us and peep it
out thank you
brandon you'll come i'll i'll check your
nuts out do not come dude that is
well i'm not gonna come but i'm gonna
check his nose oh thank god you guys
before we set him on this little this
this innocent girl from montana you see
what she's signing up for
that other girl does mma i think you i
don't know i just feel like there's
these are great opportunities man
and these are a lot of close far if you
want to get out in the mountains you
want to get out and have a new
experience man i just don't want you
to miss out on a good opportunity man
i've done it in my life look i've done
it in my life and i regret it
yeah we got to work on confidence
because i think you're a catch and a
good person
so you think my confidence is low yeah
you're also wearing a
child's pajama top okay yeah because
he's confident
figure it out man
yeah that's a good point who wants a
bedtime story
that's a great shirt by the way thanks
man guccifer
um yeah we should work on confidence
work on
lubing up them nuts and then obviously
the shipping it up
brushing my teeth deodorant yep we're
getting soap
we gotta give you a makeover value for
the date yeah you can do this in a half
hour in the morning yeah we're trying to
find
out my hair get a good hairstyle going
i'm gonna style you through the date
with some hair jello you're on crazy
you're doing what's wrong with you now
we're trying to get things going we're
talking about hair gel
about brushing my teeth washing my nuts
you two are trying to get things going
hey papa hey papa i'm not gonna lie to
you a month from now
we're gonna be doing the same thing with
you yeah yeah
i'm trying to help one before i help you
and i appreciate it
this is the trial run over here dude
yeah dude would you sound like me i
think the worst part is i see myself
in my head yeah
let us take care of it and you got to
get out of your head and we're going to
make this happen because when i saw
myself i cringed i'm like is that like
you know that's
the same song didn't help you've been
making choices for yourself for long
enough and it hasn't gotten you to where
you want to be i don't think
in a love space but maybe i have been
seeing someone too um
what uh oh why does this happen every
day i know not again
i'm in oklahoma next week thursday
through saturday
brickstown comedy club oklahoma city
june 10th through the 12th
stevie we love you man we're going to
find you love you guys brendan and theo
fighter and weight i got to go in and go
hard in the paint i do not think
i am in flow black rifle coffee i'm
ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrage is thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ain't the queso in the case of
ritos
but everything's gonna be fine hate on
me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brendan's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]